what's up man how you been
why I don't say it you ready for March
Madness I love this time of year man
what's up guys it's Zach TTG I'm here
with NCAA Champion Carlos Boozer Ritz
toasted chips has brought us together to
talk about the most wonderful time of
year March Madness there it is so Carlos
what is your favorite March Madness
memory I mean when we want it duh no I
mean obviously 2001 when we got a chance
to win a championship that's like the
best moment you work all year long for
that moment so when we got to the final
four that game we were down about 22 in
the first half coach gets in the
huddling those guys we're going to win
this game second half we felt more
confident we went out won that game
which was like a crazy combat and then
we play Arizona in the championship game
when you win that Championship when you
cut that net down I feel like it all
paid off man you get back to campus how
was that reception when you got back man
oh my God it's amazing I mean we had
school off for like a week thank you
Dean We Appreciate You Dean man we got a
toast today yeah that was click clink
that was beautiful yeah
bracket time yeah of course you got to
fill out a bracket a couple brackets
yeah get into you know a little bracket
battle with people I think it's fun when
you've got a group of people around
watching the TV watching who you pick
how do you do your bracket there's
always multiple brackets you know I'll
have a bracket where I'm just being
analytical I'm gonna have another
bracket where there's some upsets any
game could be an upset exactly Mario
Chalmers hitting that shot Kansas and
Kansas yeah to beat D Rose in Memphis
Carmelo as a freshman going through the
tournament winning at Syracuse as a
freshman there's so many it's like
Cinderella stories that happened all the
all the moments that make March Madness
March Madness see I'm not even sure what
I'm gonna pick this year but I do know
what snacks I'm picking yeah for when
I'm watching the game because these are
amazing the Ritz toasted chips for the
win
how you like watching the games you like
to be solo you like to be in a group
tell me about it I like to watch it with
friends how do you like to watch it I
like to watch it with friends man like I
think it's fun when you got a group of
people a lot of times I'm calling Vince
Carter to say hey how's your
are they making it this year bro yeah I
think this is one of those moments where
you're going to see guys bring out all
their snacks and you see the Ritz
toasted chips oh yeah right here you'll
see tons of these all sprinkled around
the country watching college basketball
so this is one of those moments that
brings people together thank you for all
the insight into the tournament they I
mean somebody like me that wasn't in it
never would have experienced man I I
really appreciate it it was great man
appreciate you man yes sir and thank you
to Rich toasted chips for bringing us
together
man these are good pretty good chips man
I'm taking this mold with me